welcome to the dave ramsey show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have
money and a career you are the hero in
your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show where dad is dumb
cash is king and the paid off home
mortgage has taken the place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice dr john
deloney ramsey personality best-selling
author of the book redefining anxiety is
my co-host today
as we talk to you about your life and
your money
so you've got questions about the people
you're going to see this week known as
crazy relatives
john's here he's got a degree in
counseling he cannot help you
i can tell you what i'm doing that's all
man
oh wait a minute you just called your
relatives crazy be careful there that's
the broadcast
you know what by this time we all know
those cats are out of the barn
they are what they are all right cats
are out of the wine
okay all right good i know you kept cats
in a barn in texas
i don't know what's in the barn in texas
okay all right just checking
just checking the horses out of the barn
who comes out of the barn
cattle usually but uh what do i know all
right open phones at triple eight eight
two five
five two two five let's move on from the
farm animal anthology here
and we will talk to you about your life
and your money diana is gonna start us
off in san bernardino california
merry christmas diana merry christmas
dave hi dr d how are you guys today
great how can we help good well i was
calling
i might get emotional sorry i'm a widow
my husband died a year and a half ago
and
my kids um get a social security
survivor benefit
it's 900 each a month until they're 18.
my son is um 10. my daughter is eight
and i just want to know how to be the
best steward of that money for them i
i myself um i'm a teacher i um
thankfully through
covet and all of this i still work um i
make ninety two thousand dollars a year
um and i'm myself i'm on baby step two
i'm trying to kick sally made to the
curb
um but i live on what i make and i don't
use that money for anything else and
i just want to know what to do with it
for them okay
wow what a hard time you been through
i'm so sorry
thank you um well
my my opinion on this is very strong
like most of my opinions
um you spend way more than 900
per child per month to take care of
those children
it takes more than that to buy food
lights
water clothing and so on
for an individual in san bernardino
california
and so if i were you i would simply take
that 1800
a month and make it part of your budget
and your budget should take care of your
family first food shelter clothing
transportation and utilities
and then it should start working on the
future working your baby steps
and you would say for kids college and
you would save for retirement
and you'd work to pay off your home and
this is all after you clear sallie mae
to the curb
but clearing sally made the curb as a
gift to your children
because it puts you in a position then
to send them to school
and you save for that there is no law
nor any ethic no nor any moral
obligation for you to set this 1800
aside somewhere while you on the left
side
uh i set it over to the right while you
on the left are starving to death
you're not starving at 92 000 but you're
not like
filthy rich or something either right
that's right so your budget is tight
enough and
i just put the 1800 bucks in there same
thing with child support
you're not obligated to set child
support aside for children because you
spend
more you single parents out there you
spend more on that kid than the child
support is
right in every state in america
you spend more on that kid than the
child support is so
it's not like you're getting rich off a
child support any of you out there that
are living on this so
just mix it in as part of your budget so
i just want to give you the freedom to
do that because you got enough
things on your plate without being
shamed or guilted
about this 1800 bucks and in diana
sometimes when
when we're dealing with grief and it
looks like you're about six months into
trying to reconfigure what your head and
heart and world is going to look like
for those two little kids and then covet
hit
and you've had to navigate this by
yourself right
yes there's this there's this
mythological notion that
if you just follow these steps in the
right order and do the right things
that it will make the passing of someone
that you love okay
and dave is right there is no magical
use for this money
you'd give every penny of it back to
have this guy back
sitting at your kitchen table you know
that we know that
and then we also have to recognize
that's not gonna happen
and so the next right thing to do is to
work
hard and diligently and intentionally on
dealing with the loss of your husband
it's going to take years and years and
minutes and some minutes
love those kids and he said man use this
money as though it is part of your
income and
rock on and go from there because it is
part of your income
that's what it's designed for if the uh
if the
law was that it had to be set aside for
children they would force you to set it
aside for children it doesn't it comes
to you
to take care of your children and the
assumption in the law is accurate
is that a mom is going to take care of
her kids right and um
very few times does that assumption not
play out
um i and we would call those bad parents
you know and you said which is a whole
different issue
getting out of debt letting that that
pressure off of you like taking that
weight off of you that's a gift to your
kids
right use that money get out of debt and
mathematically it sets her up to be able
to care for them
in the next stages as well that's right
and so this idea that somehow people
have it in their head that it needs to
be separated off or whatever and
it's part of that magical grieving in
that magical thinking there
yeah and you know another situation
where the exact same question the exact
same answer comes up is
uh someone gets divorced and they get
they're getting child support and then
they get remarried
and so now they've got a household
income that concerns a step parent step
father stepmother
and then you're getting child support on
the other side and you got an income
from the other
is it okay to mix that in yeah it's
absolutely mixed in because that step
parent is
freaking writing checks taking care of
these kids that's right that's part of
the deal
and they're they're paying for that roof
over the head they're paying for that
electricity
they're paying for that water bill when
that kid flushes that commode 63
thousand times
you know and sticks the rabbit the
stuffed rabbit in there and it leaks for
24 hours
or they never flush it's that one too oh
but now you see you had to go there i'm
just
i was trying to run up a bill you just
got gross okay
no man hey i'm living it i'm living it
oh i wish they were flushing 63 times a
day
oh man you'd gladly pay the water
no but yes but yes
but yes oh you're out in the country
you're on a well aren't you
yes there you go it doesn't cost much
all right
so where the cats are in the barn
[Laughter]
in these tennessee barns right for the
record
for the record america i have a cat
that's living in the barn no
and you're a cat guy no they just you're
so you're a barn
i'm a dog guy okay you're a barn cat guy
right cats belong in the barn i'm the
husband of a i mean the father of a
son and a little girl and they saw this
barn
cat and how such it is such as it is and
so the tragedy begins
so the tragedy has begun they're dead
it's all
unraveled the grinch is my co-host to
this hour very few principles
open phones at triple eight eight two
five five two two five dr john deloney
two phds and can't figure out what to do
with a barn cat we'll be back
on the dave ramsey show
[Music]
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find health
care coverage that would meet our needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
the medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm is here to meet the needs of
your growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality uh
writer of the best-selling book
redefining anxiety
what it is what it is not and how to get
your life back
if you want to talk about that type of
thing and talk about your life and maybe
boundary issues or whatever else is
going on in your family he's here
today with me and we'll certainly take
your questions about life and money
the phone number triple eight eight two
five five
two two five mo is next in belgium hey
mo how are you
hey dave hi john how are you guys doing
i'm doing great
good how can we help uh it's a
it's a money-based question so sorry
john the emotional things are not
necessary with me so the question that i
have is actually about i started a
business a year ago
and uh it's it's been doing okay with
with the cash flow but uh i'm just
asking about what is the best way to
invest my money like and what should i
do just pay myself out and
do something with that or keep it in the
business and invest in something else
you know well i i you know there's three
things that i invest in i put money back
into my business i put money in mutual
funds and i put money in real estate
i do not know the real estate landscape
in belgium well enough to tell you if
that's a good investment or not you
probably could tell me
and uh and what types of vehicles you've
got that are similar to mutual funds
that you can get into
yeah yes so i actually uh i don't know
much about
investing or anything i actually know a
lot about housing and
i really think housing is a good
investment
in in belgium okay all right
i'm just uh just thinking about what
should i
keep the money in the business and buy
it buy houses from the business or
put it on my personal accounts and
pay the taxes on that and then buy the
houses
again i don't know the tax implications
there
but if all things are equal i would have
them separate from your business because
you wouldn't want
your business to appear to be so wealthy
that it became a target for lawsuits
and so i don't own any real estate
inside my
ramsey solutions business ramsey
solutions is actually a tenant
of mine uh on another on another company
that owns the building
and so um you know you've the structure
that way
is typically good risk management to not
have all your investments in
one entity um and that would include you
know separating your business from your
real estate
um and even with real estate once it
gets to a certain size
i would have a different entity in the
states we use an entity called the an
llc for real estate
and i don't get but about five to ten
million dollars worth of real estate
into an llc and then i open another one
because i don't want if someone sued us
that got hurt on a property or something
and we lost
everything in that llc that would be all
there is that they would get
it's limited to whatever that holds and
then the other buckets
the other llc's are safe they're
protected from that
and so um you know that that's just risk
management once you get it to a certain
level of
wealth that you spread around the target
so that it's a series of smaller targets
not a super large singular target
and so that's why i would not put it in
the business again i am not familiar
with structuring stuff in belgium though
i
would be known as clueless but
conceptually you want to spread that
risk around
open phones at triple eight eight two
five 825-5225 jefferson phoenix hi
jeff how are you i'm doing well dave how
are you
great how can we help okay just wanted
to get some feedback from you the
situation
is um my daughter uh finishes
finished her bachelor's degree back in
the may she's been accepted
into a graduate occupational therapy
program
i've talked to the finance people there
run through the numbers done some
financial modeling
and it looks like after
if you consider the loan she would take
and i would pay for the plus loans but
she would pay have to take on the direct
loans
the program is about three years long
the numbers show that uh given those
factors
and the interest on those loans when she
graduates that she would graduate
with about 88 000 of student loan loan
debt
so the the fly in the ointment is she
has a pretty good job right now
so she's considered deferring for a year
on this job we can can certainly
estimate
that she should be able to make about 60
to 70
000 a year yep and
um so we think uh
after taxes and expenses if she lives
conservatively she could have about
40 to 45 000 um
saved to apply toward the debt and not
have to go in as much debt if she
deferred a year
what you're going to get your input on
what your thoughts are should you just
go and start the program and buy it
the bullets or wait and
use this chunk of money to pay for the
program so she doesn't have to go into
debt so much
absolutely under no circumstances do you
borrow money at all
any a penny of it for an ot program
period
so the magic about an ot program is they
make you feel like you were
you know what we scoured earth and
you're the one
we accepted you and the reality is
there's a ton of empty seats
in a number of these graduate programs
across the country
and the tide is turned in many many many
academic programs where there's more
seats than there are students which what
does that mean that means next year that
means the year
after after she works her butt off for
two years and decides this is really
really what i want to do
then she saved up 80 grand and she can
go write a check and it's going to be a
painful check
and she's going to pay cash for that job
and then she's going to walk out
and as an ot dave you may have seen
different numbers but we're talking 65
to 80
000 bucks a year being an ot depending
on where you're doing the work and so
if she's doing it to make more money or
to quote unquote move up
she's already got a pretty good job and
so i'd really dig in as to why she wants
to do that but under no circumstances do
you borrow money
jeff just to give you a little context
john has a phd in higher ed
and has served on served in universities
all over america
later lately as dean of students so this
is not something he just made up
uh he's lived this for decades my
opinion is the same thing
ot is treated like your medical student
or something like you
uh we're given a gift from heaven to be
let in and that's a bunch of hogwash
ot is not med school and it shouldn't
cost like med school and some of them
try to charge for it like it's med
school
we know it's not med school because you
make 60 to 80 coming out not 160 to 180
coming
out that's how we know it's not med
school and so
i i think it's overrated uh i'm not sure
that's what she wants to do i think she
just got in this track
and then got accepted and felt approval
from being accepted
and i'm trying to john's trying to
truncate that and so am i so definitely
work a year
uh the other thing i would try to do is
i try to work a year or two
in the freaking field so she can get in
there and get her hands in the middle of
occupational therapy and figure out if
it's what she really wants to do oh by
the way the company she's working for
may pay her tuition after that to go up
and finish her master's
and go ahead and get the degree free i'd
be okay with
going in student loan debt for anything
is a bad idea i
really would beg you not to go into
student loan debt you or her
for this right of any amount not two
dollars worth
oh and by the way there's a vast array
of
charges depending on which school you
get approved for
that's right there's books and fees and
hospital charges
no what i'm saying is that school a may
be double what school b
yeah yeah yeah school b may be half of
this
and again this idea that oh that's the
one i got accepted in they
they picked me they picked me and i'm
special and
bull crap you know this you are shopping
for
the cheapest eggs man and you just get
the you go to the store to store and get
the cheapest eggs is their eggs
and because no one ever walks into an
occupational therapy's office and goes
uh you know i see you went to that
school i don't think i'll come
i'm out right no one even asks where you
went to school
they're not even positive you did go to
school
i now i'm a nerd and i had both of my
knees done two summers ago and my
occupational therapist was incredible
and i did ask hey where'd you go to
school after after oh i wasn't gonna
walk out
yeah well you couldn't your knees are
messed up that's right that's right
strapped to the table anyway
but yeah i want my ot to be awesome
to be a bunch of lawyers in my life a
bunch of docs and i've never asked one
where they went to school
because i'm just not impressed with your
pedigree all i know is can you fix
what's broken
that's all i want to know and so this
idea you paid double
because you went to that school it's
laughable
it's just laughable don't do it so yeah
we'll take them take a year off
preferably working in the field and then
get free tuition this is my best course
of action on this
this is the dave ramsey show
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country or have a
better life
the army national guard can help get you
there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com to find out more
[Music]
dr chondaloni ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the air open
phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
cliff
and ryan are with us in cleveland ohio
hey guys how are you good dave how are
you
very cool i see on my screen you're debt
free congratulations
thank you love it how much have you paid
off
71 113
love it how long did this take don't
want to forget the 52 that's right get
the 52 cents in there
i came out of the corner of the couch
right so uh how long did this take
well uh just under two years so right
right around 23 months
okay very good and your range of income
during that time
uh 113 to 117.
okay cool what do y'all do for a living
we both work in
television broadcast production actually
very cool
i work in professional sports and cliff
works in television
okay local affiliate there yes
okay great yep very cool what kind of
debt was the 71 000
well it was a range we had cards and
cards and cards
uh four credit cards uh store credit
cards
uh credit union credit card
both of our school loans and then a
vehicle vehicle loan and then a home
improvement loan
what was the big one
those pesky student loans i think they
were the biggest student loans are
gigantic
okay old pesky sallie mae had to go how
long you guys been married
sally how long you guys been married
we've been married just over 11 years
okay we've been together about
17. so what happened two years ago this
sets you guys on fire what's the story
to this journey
so a lot of my family had been
mentioning your name at various holidays
and i always brushed you off
and you know i thought we were good with
our money we had good debt you know like
everybody says you're
you have you should have good debt and
then fast forward a couple months
and my best friend whitney came over and
she pulls out these white envelopes
and i was like what are those you know
we were just trying to pay for some
pizza
and she's like oh these are my cash
envelopes i'm following this dave ramsey
plan and i'm like wait a minute my
family talks about this guy like who
is he you know and then i brushed it off
again and
fast forward to july of 2018
and i just couldn't get you out of my
head dave and so i googled you
and you happen to be running a christmas
in july special
and lucky for me i was able to get the
bundle of the total money makeover
rachel's book live your life not theirs
and then a kids financial piece set for
our son
and we created our first budget that day
on every dollar
i read the total money makeover in two
days flat
and we immediately performed plastic
surgery on all our credit cards
became mega gazelle intense and
literally the rest was history
cliff how did you keep up because once
she stepped on the gas she went
yeah so a little whiplash
that's good oh so you know
at what point did you join into this
process
um well like she said we were together
um
over her friend's house um and like she
said the family
talked about it all the time and and you
know we're like
we get in the car driving driving home
and we're like
what are they even talking about like
what what is this thing what is this
thing
you know you get more and more
interested and then next thing you know
you're reading books and
paying off debt okay so you were in
there right from the start with her then
oh for sure okay all right very good
congratulations you guys we're so proud
of you thank you so as a part of people
fantastic
as a part of this journey cliff and ryan
what happened to your marriage i'm
always fascinated by
these joint journeys people go on and
what happens to their marriage
i mean it definitely strengthened it and
also
the communication especially because i
do think that's one of the main keys of
getting
out of debt and being on this journey is
just clear open
constant communication i mean just the
way that it
you have to have that between the two of
you
and then i think um dreaming together
for what the future holds for us now
that we
are on our way to financial freedom and
dreaming together
alone and then for our family
say that again we talk about retirement
all the time now it's a real thing
it's it's not a boogie man the closet
waiting to pounce later it's really
something you're gonna
make happen it's within reach for sure
yeah
yeah way to go guys very very proud of
you
so this is 23. really tough months 35
000 a year about 3 000
a month average that you paid off during
this time
what was the toughest part of this
uh i would say saying no and realizing
that was
a complete sentence um especially to our
son
he was at he was you know eight and nine
years old and
having to say no to him a lot for
certain things
that now he throws back in our face
which is hilarious
you know you said no to me all these
times now let's order as much pizza as
we want
so i would say saying no to him was
definitely hard
and then the last big debt
of our snowball because we weren't
getting those small victories that you
get at the beginning to like keep the
motivation going
so i had to create some sort of reward
or treat for ourselves
for every thousand dollars that we ended
up knocking off
of that last debt so those those are the
two hardest parts i think
very cool yeah you know what look
saying no to certain sports um for kids
and and for parents is is kind of
difficult but when you know it's going
to be a short term
decision um it makes it a lot easier
so i know there's families all over the
country that listen to this and and
tell themselves i've got two little kids
we just
can't get we can't do that right now
this isn't the right season
so you're living proof you've got two
beautiful little kids i'm looking here
on the monitor
your kids survived right they made it
yep
and everybody's okay and safe and fed
and all that
yep and they're stronger on the other
end yeah they're not they're
not going into counseling for missing a
pizza right right
right or something we have an
understanding of
the sacrifices that we were
having to take on in order to put
ourselves in better success
financially for the future yeah way to
go you guys i love it
today it it is now is the right time
today is the right time
to get started yeah hogan says some days
not on the calendar
all right it's always too late to wait
it's never too late to start
yeah never too late to get a great head
start on something
well done you guys well done we're so
proud of you your heroes you took
control of your life
changed your family tree you absolutely
rocked this well done we got a copy of
chris hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires
we definitely want that to be the next
chapter in your story you truly have
lived like no one else and now you're
going to be in a position to live
and give like no one else including all
the pizza you want
[Laughter]
71 000 paid off in 23 months making 113
to 117.
count it down let's hear a debt free
scream
three two one a
b c d word
[Music]
yeah this is how it's done
oh fabulously done man
what she said um about the impact on
marriage
is essential right we take calls
virtually
every hour on this show about well can i
do this without my spouse and i'll get
my spouse involved my spouse my spouse
my spells
and on top of that you know we've got
seven million people have been through
financial peace university now so we
actually know what we're talking about
when it comes to
it's almost impossible to do this
against the will of your spouse
right and not only that when you do it
on the other side with your spouse
you find yourself closer sweeter yeah
communication's increased unity has
increased
unified vision that you created together
yeah we're
truly walking out this as the preacher
said and now you are one
there it is and now you are one this is
the dave ramsey show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple h
825-5225 mitch is in cleveland ohio hi
mitch welcome to the dave ramsey show
merry christmas guys thanks for having
me merry christmas to you what's up
i've got kind of a two-part money
housing question but i also want to tell
dr delonia i've
never been a big psychology guy but i'm
pretty hooked on your show i like the
podcast so keep it up
well i appreciate you thanks for
listening it's i think it's you and my
mom right now so i appreciate you man
[Laughter]
there's probably more yeah yeah my
question is
i'm 26 i'm on baby step four i'm
excited to buy my first house in the
spring
i'm trying to decide if i should if i
should consider
buying a duplex and renting it because i
can get one for about the same price
as a single family and then i've got
roughly
75 000 cash 18 or so with my emergency
fund
and so i'm trying to decide exactly how
much to put down because i would
i wouldn't mind keeping a little extra
cash too so i was thinking more like 50
000 which is a little more than twenty
percent
but just wanted some some guidance on
whether you whether you think that's a
good move on either one of those
i'd hold your emergency fund if you want
to keep it at six months instead of
three that's fine with me
and beyond that i put everything else on
the house the idea the more you put down
the less you got to pay off
sure what about the duplex
uh duplex is fine uh the
good news is your renter lives next door
the bad news is your renter lives next
door
and uh the other thing is is that the
buyer when you get ready to sell it is
more of a wholesale investor than a
retail joe and susie buyer
with a picket fence and a little puppy
dog that they want to live in the house
with
and that that single family's gonna
appreciate
all things being equal faster than a
duplex will in most markets
because of who the buyer is on the other
side
and uh duplex buyers are typically
not owner occupants you would be one of
the rare exceptions
i get this question on the air fairly
often but it's still
out of all the number of duplexes in the
united states the vast majority are
owned by
non-owner occupants and so that's
typically who your buyer is
i didn't know that that's new
information for me
that's good to know because i i thought
they were all i'm gonna buy one side and
rent out the other side and knock out
this mortgage hardly any of them hmm
most of them are matter of fact i used
to buy when i was buying real estate
back in the day i'd buy like a whole
street of them
right you know about like 10 of them or
15 of them or something like that
and it just turns into a little a
miniature apartment complex sort of
thing
like that or if you own 10 or 15 i'm all
over town even it's the same situation
so it's now i mean there are people
doing now the zero lot line
looks like a duplex but you own half of
it or
and it's called different things in
different markets but it's a meaning you
should
have a shared wall a single but it's not
a technically a condominium in most
cases
and so um those are almost all owner
occupied
right um depending on the market and you
know depend on the city and what's going
on there but
but um yeah you just think about the
property and go okay who's your buyer on
the other end and
how sophisticated are they and are they
gonna a retail buyer or a wholesale
buyer
obviously if their wholesale buyer the
property is not going to appreciate as
much tim's in milwaukee hi
tim how are you better than i deserve
dave
thanks for taking my call sure man
well i got a question for you my wife
and i are looking at paying off our home
good got a balance on it right now 83
000
and we have about 375 000 sitting in
uh tax deferred accounts
and we have our emergency fund fully
funded and
our concern is that if we only pay off
this house right now
we're gonna have a tax bill of about
eighteen thousand dollars
due um my concern would be
one of two things do we go and go ahead
and do it
pay the house off paid 83 000 and then
just stop contributing to our deferred
comp
or our retirement next year just to fund
uh the taxes how old are you guys
um i'm 54 my wife's 49.
okay and so what type of account is this
that you can pull it out without a
penalty
uh mine's in the deferred comp so i'm
a retired law enforcement okay so you
can get that with
only being taxed with no penalty then in
your situation
that's correct okay
yeah i'd pay off the house and uh i'd
wait
for i'd wait after the first year to do
it so your tax bill is not due
for uh 14 months or 15 months then
okay and that gives you that time to if
you want to pull the plug on the
deferred comp and
build up the 18 000 that'd be the same
thing um
it'd be really neat if you could do the
deferred comp and cash flow
the 18 000 during that 15 months that
you've got to save it up
that was my question what's the what's
your what's your
payment every month what's your mortgage
it's only 392
oh wow okay okay what's your household
income
about 120 000. okay you might be able to
continue your deferred comp
and save 18 000 in 15 months
if you wait till january to do this that
would be
best of all worlds because that way
you're paying your taxes out of pocket
which has in effect
mathematically is the same thing as
investing that much more is the way
it'll turn out
and because otherwise you would have
pulled the money out of there to pay the
taxes and would have lost that much
so or not put it in which is the same
thing again so
basically by doing both we're adding to
the net effect of your investments i'd
pay it off yeah but i'd wait till
january to do it
hey thanks for the call open phones at
triple eight eight two five
five two two five connor is in seattle
washington hey connor welcome to the
dave ramsey show merry christmas
hey dave and john merry christmas thanks
for taking my call honored to be on with
you guys
you too how can we help okay um
so i'm 27. babysit four five and six
and i've been thinking about looking for
a house
um pretty soon here my mother and father
are starting to go through
they're going through their will again
and my mom has presented me with kind of
a
what what feels to me like an unusual um
option so she's letting me know that i
have about
750 000 inheritance coming whenever
whenever they they pass away
she has given me the option to purchase
the house that i'm living in
which is their house from them at a
discounted rate
um and it wouldn't be quite 750 000 but
um i've been just kind of trying to
figure out how to run the numbers
figure out if this is a good choice for
me or if i should
i guess politely decline the house
they're currently living in
no excuse me one of their rental homes
that i am renting
oh you're living in roommate okay yes
i'm cruising and so what would you be
paying for the house uh
about 600 000 okay and what is the house
worth
well i'm working on that um i think
the the main real estate sites think
anywhere between a million and a million
two
okay so you would be getting four
hundred thousand dollars of your
inheritance up front
and they would discount your inheritance
by the amount of the equity
um yeah that's correct okay
all right would you buy this house
otherwise um
well not at the price that it would
normally list that but
uh yeah if i could afford it sure i like
the house
okay well if your parents are doing a
good good estate planning they can gift
you that much under the unified estate
tax credit
as long as their uh net worth is under
40 million right now they can pull that
off
uh and uh you won't they won't have any
taxes on it you won't have any taxes on
it and you would get
400 000 less upon their death than you
would get now right
is that so you're paying full price for
the house you're just getting part of
your inheritance early
to buy the house with yeah that's
correct
uh the the inheritance part is a little
bit complicated because i have siblings
this particular 750 came from i don't
know
okay the last thing i would tell you is
this i would get the house appraised or
get a real estate
agent to give you a comparative market
analysis and it should not be at a
hundred percent
of value it should because if they sold
the house they wouldn't get 100 value
they'd get about 80 percent of value or
88 percent of value
so somewhere around 85 percent of value
minus the mortgage
is the amount deducted from your
inheritance and then yeah there's no
reason not to do that deal
as long as you can afford the 600 000
mortgage this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
the total debt is around six hundred and
forty thousand dollars
i want him to come clean about a credit
card that he doesn't know about i am
going to probably pay
student loans for the rest of my life i
just don't even know where to begin
and i don't know what to do i'm not
scared welcome to the dave ramsey show
live from the headquarters of ramsay
solutions broadcasting from the dollar
car rental studios it's the dave ramsey
show
you guys dumb ass everything just
as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality ho uh
author of redefining anxiety a
best-selling book now
is our co-host today here on the air
he's answering your questions about
life emotional well-being and
crazy relatives at christmas
[Laughter]
and we're going to talk about your money
and your life as well the phone number
is triple eight eight two five
five two two five lindsay is
with us in amarillo texas hi lindsay
welcome to the dave ramsey show
well hey y'all merry christmas merry
christmas to you what's
up okay i have a question slash
marital debate that i'm going to ask you
to help me with i'll get out
my whistle and my striped shirt okay
thank you might need it
my husband and i are on baby step two we
have paid off forty seven thousand
dollars this year
wow we found out recently i know right
we kick a butt
but we found out recently we're
expecting our first baby
in april congratulations
thank you um so now we're in store mode
we've been saving up
um now it's time to start thinking about
nursery stuff
and given that we're first-time parents
we have no idea
kind of what to expect as far as how
much this is going to cost to
furnish a nursery so my parents wanted
to bless us
and they gifted us with fifteen hundred
dollars and said this is for you to
furnish a nursery with
well my husband is very much in the baby
step two we're gonna save us and pay off
debt vote and he's like
that is just more room for our shovel we
need to pile it on baby step two
and let the baby sleep on the floor what
kind of guy is this
i mean he's very he's logical and i
think his heart is in the right place
you know he's like i'm talking about
long term what's best for our daughter
is to pay off
our debt as soon as we can so we should
be shopping facebook marketplace
craigslist like
getting anything used or free or donated
we can but i'm like well this was a gift
and it's not
out of our income it was to bless us to
help prepare for this baby
and so we're going back and forth i'm
like what is okay to budget
how much money should we say i'll go
ahead and throw the flag i'll go and
throw the flag blow the whistle
all right he he's uh he's out of bounds
you win and the only
the only reason is the only reason is
this that your parents
bought furniture
for your nursery that's what they did
now are you going to take it back and
get a refund
and go buy used furniture so that you
can put on the dead snowball
well that would be ludicrous yeah
and this is the same thing yeah this
because
they did not give you a gift with no
strings attached
they in a sense walked with you to the
store and bought the nursery furniture
they just let you pick it out what it
looks in this case they're just letting
you pick it out they didn't say
well y'all do whatever you want do
something nice for the baby
they said furniture in the freaking
nursery it was very specific right
right yeah yes there and so it would be
dishonoring to the gift
to do anything with it other than what
they said now had they given you fifteen
thousand dollars not fifteen hundred
dollars
i'd be having a discussion with your
mother and your dad
about that's a little nuts and we need
permission to use some of this to get
out of debt
because it's a little over the top we
don't even make that kind of money
okay but fifteen hundred dollars is not
not going to change your life or the
child's life one way or the other
in these days that will buy you about 11
diapers so that's good
don't do that to me dr d do not tell me
that i'm just telling you
what what is your household income we
make a combined income about a hundred
thousand a year
yeah okay so this is one and a half
percent of your income
yeah it's irrelevant and
it's a for somebody who's gazelle
intense
fifteen hundred dollars can feel like a
million bucks
and so accept it accept it and live in
it and love it
yeah and by the way you're not supposed
to be paying on your debt snowball with
a baby on the way anyway you're supposed
to be stopped
push pause probably we put back probably
eleven thousand savings right now and so
this money yeah but but now had your mom
and dad been more vague
about the verbage around the gift we
might have a different discussion but
they were very precise
it is as if they took you to the store
and you picked it out and they wrote the
check
and then you're wanting to take it back
and put it on and get a refund and put
it on debt and buy use furniture at a
garage sale
no we're not doing that that's that's
just dishonoring to the gift
again if the numbers were out of whack
i'd have a discussion with the giver
and and get asked to be released from
the obligation
but um you know
it that would just be out of whack and
now lindsay you get one
one look at him in the eyes one
i told you so and then after that you
gotta say
thank you for being a husband who's
sticking to our convictions no i don't
even think she gets one she just said
just blame it on me as dave said dave
all right so you get one day if you get
one dive set and then be grateful that
you got a husband that's
committed to this plan long time
absolutely because he's gonna look he's
gonna be a great provider oh man
and um not super ethical but a good prov
i'm just kidding
no he's good he's good you're lucky
lindsey
hillary good team he's a he's a good guy
and you know
and now some of your parents you guys
need to think that to me
the ethics don't change but the ratios
make the discussion weirder okay like i
had a young couple on time
that i was coaching a thousand years ago
and their household income was twenty
six thousand dollars
once they got married and two weeks
after they got married her dad
shows up and hands them the keys to a
forty thousand dollar paid for
car and they have sixty thousand dollars
in student loan debt
now do they sell that car and pay off
the student loan yeah yeah you put them
in a
weird position right there i do i'm
going to but dad's going to be pissed
right and i told him i said you need to
call your dad and tell him that this was
silly
and he didn't even talk to him about it
he just shows up the goob there's going
con
manipulation control freak stuff in that
too well he just thought
he wanted us to have a safe car yeah
bull he wanted to
show off and if you're creating a
nursery
not for your baby but for the instagram
photo
that's a problem right when you set up
i see these nurseries that are lighting
systems
oh my god these fancy furniture and
gizmos and contraptions that little baby
for the first six to nine months will
want one thing you
real close to them food in a dry diaper
well
and whatever you spend on it they're
going to poop on it so just get ready
exactly
so and so anyway buy a nice
set up a a a nursery but don't go
overboard
1500 that's what i'm saying it's perfect
1500 that's perfect 15 000.
i'm i'm calling i'm gonna throw the flag
the other way on mom and dad
and go look that's out of line i know
you're excited about the first grandbaby
i was too
uh but you know we had to learn
boundaries with our grown kids
and not go dropping grenades in their
house
i'll take it i'll take a little plug
roll it into the living room and see how
this works out right to see how the
in-laws act okay
see how yes and and papa dave has done
screwed up something again
seagull management swoop and poop swoop
in and poop
america anyone who wants to throw a
fifteen thousand dollar grenade
my way we will figure that out on the
fly you'll catch it i'm committed you're
okay i'll turn it out as we go that's
right you can be bribed
i will figure that out of ethics i'll
figure it out this is the dave ramsey
[Music]
show
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com will help you every
step of the way just like they've helped
thousands of my listeners
with free design help by phone and
online
plus they guarantee the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
if you want to get some quick advice on
life and money but only have a few
minutes we're excited to tell you about
our latest podcast called the ramsey
call of the day
that'll give you the life-changing
content that you get here but
in under 10 minutes i'll be i'll be on
it along with ramsey network
personalities ken coleman rachel cruz
chris hogan christy wright anthony
o'neil
and my co-host today dr john deloney the
ramsey call of the day could be anything
from an inspirational story of knocking
out debt to tips on how to deal with
loss of income
or how to make decisions in this crazy
world
subscribe to ramsey call of the day on
spotify apple podcasts or the ramsey
network app
or listen on your smart speaker by
saying
play ramsey call of the day
as a matter of fact if your smart
speaker heard me say that it probably
just started doing it
there you go that's how that works
blinds.com is our question of the day
they have a 100 satisfaction guarantee
that means even if you mismeasure you
pick the wrong color they will remake
your window blinds for free
free samples free shipping with the new
promos they run all the time
always use the promo code ramsey and you
can get a good deal
alright today's question comes from
roger in kentucky
roger writes my wife and i have been
married 10 years and we have three
children
i work as a federal law enforcement
officer and my wife is a teacher
assistant we make about a hundred and
ten thousand dollars combined and we own
two
houses which one is a rental property
the issue i have is my wife
keeps failing her final year in college
and it's getting too expensive to keep
letting her return
she's been attending college over the
past eight years
i want to move for my career progression
but she doesn't want to leave
i could take a promotion in another
state and make a hundred thousand
dollars on my own
what should i do i really wish my wife
would find another job
i've explained to her if she was making
more money i could ease up on
overtime and be home more dave there's a
lot here
here's what i'll just call out
immediately if you've been in college
for eight years
and you continue to fail your last year
your last semester it's not because
you're not smart enough
it's not because there isn't the
academic support and help and assistance
for you
there's something else at play here
whether somebody is choosing or they are
not intentionally but sabotaging
themselves
or this is the last shred of control
this wife in this relationship
has but there's something bigger going
on here than just simply
i can't get past that last semester in
college now of course depending on
whether you make it through
three years of college they're going to
help out funking out
right you have the intellectual gray
matter to make it through the last year
you are correct so i'm calling bs
that's right and so what i this sounds
harsh when i say it this way
but if you choose not to get the
assistance
the tutoring the support and put it this
way colleges have an incentive
to help you graduate because that helps
them with their rankings that helps them
with a number of
internal metrics failing eight years in
a row is in their last
semester is not good for their rep it
reflects bad on the college right
so if you are choosing to not do the
things you need to do to pass
yeah like go to class do the homework
take the test study for the test that
kind of stuff
then you are choosing to fail yeah
either intentionally or
um subconsciously for to not get all
psychobabble so
there's something else going on here
roger that sounds like you and your wife
are not on the same page and this is the
last shred of control she has
in this house you think about tanking
this deal that that's her
holding on to what
probably not intentionally because he he
because he wants her to go to work and
big time and instead of just being an
assistant and make some money and she's
afraid of doing that
so the way to avoid that sabotage not
that directly
but it might be i'm up with the kids
late i got to get up super early
i don't feel good little timmy was sick
today so i couldn't go to class
i wasn't able to go to tutoring for this
exam i had to miss this exam
so you create this ecosystem where you
are unintentionally not
intentional right and you are not
successful
with your final goal and he wants to
move he wants her to make more money he
wants her to get another job and i don't
hear a lot about
what does she want to do what role does
she see herself
what does she envision herself playing
in this family and it sounds like roger
and his wife are not together
they're not unified in this for sure
right
so what's the recommendation what do
they do the recommendation is
roger has some very clear goals for his
wife
i'm going to recommend that roger back
out of the here's what you should be
doing and here's what we could be doing
if
and he needs to sit down and ask his
wife what do you want to do
do you want to be a stay-at-home mom
what's your perfect world look like in
five years there you go
and how do i help us get there how do we
get there together
yeah and he might want to move he might
want to
she doesn't want to leave well he needs
to take that into consideration they
need to have a
unified conversation here because
they're running two separate lives
they're roommates here
[Music]
so what do you think the probability is
he wants her to fail secretly
because it keeps him in it keeps his
uh narrative going where he gets to move
and take the other job
what makes him the victim right and he
gets the but he gets to throw out the um
maybe he creates the ecosystem where she
can't win
subconsciously or consciously i don't
know so that this
thing so that melts down and she has to
give up and well we got to move and take
my other job now
it could and what you get is couples who
lit get in this
self-reinforcing dance i'm the victim
i'm the victim i'm the winner i'm the
strong one i'm the one keeping the house
together i'm the one keeping the money
together
and then you get some rules nobody wants
to be in these situations and that's
when somebody's got to use your language
someone's got to throw the flag
stop the dance turn the music off get
away and say what are we doing
where are we going i love you want to
see you successful
and i feel like you're sabotaging my
desire to come home
yeah this is thick enough in this
language they probably need to sit down
with a good marriage counselor a hundred
percent
okay and have somebody just have
somebody call time out and go uh you're
in crazy cycle here
stop the crazy just a minute stop
the crazy cycle that when someone
doesn't get love then they don't give
respect and when they don't give respect
they don't give love and when they don't
give her love they don't get respect
and male female you know and around and
so begins the
washing machine dave people will
live in that dance for a decade because
they don't have one hard
stop the music conversation they just
continue and continue and continue
well you're afraid if you stop the music
it might not be a chair that's exactly
right
musical chairs right so somebody stopped
the metaphors are getting thick here but
yeah
okay wow that's very interesting there's
a lot between the lines there
a lot atlanta is on the line nick is
calling hi nick welcome to the dave
ramsey show
hi dave how you doing sir better than i
deserve what's up in your world
so uh long story short i'm 27 years old
i'm a teacher
full-time teacher i'm mary i'm engaged
to be married this upcoming july
uh with my fiancee recent
yeah thank you yeah super blessed you're
blessed for sure
um we recently got home together and uh
i guess i have kind of a two-part
question
um i just wanted to get your opinion on
if we are on a
on the on the right path doing things
the right way financially
and then also any tips that you might
have for
a successful marriage in terms of
combining finances because
like you've talked about before in the
show i want to talk to people that
have been in the game and been
successful for not not the
quick fix but the long term um so right
now
just so you know we're on baby step two
um
the only debt that we really have is is
my student loan she doesn't have any
student loan uh my student loan is about
7 500 uh i have what what will be your
household income when you do get married
in july
uh 90 000 excellent okay good
are you have you guys talked about uh
stuff like the baby steps you're
obviously acquainted with them is she
um yeah i've talked about it with her um
i listen to you pretty much every day
and uh she definitely knows who you are
i'm definitely more um more
more knowledgeable about what your
message is and what your steps are than
she is but she understands the
philosophy and
um you know i'm trying to get her on the
same same page as that as well
well i think the conversation starts
with just something like the
people who win with money and win with
relationships i'm reading
about this honey are in agreement
on their plan and so let's look at this
plan together and see if we can both
be in agreement and enthusiastic about
this plan if not we need to make up our
own that we're both in agreement
and enthusiastic about mine's not the
only way to get there
i believe with the data that we have
that is the shortest path to wealth
but uh but if you choose to go a
different way that's a pube it's more
important that you're in agreement than
that you follow me
that's what's more important and then
secondly if you wanna do it the most
efficient way i would say ours is but
you can make that decision as adults
okay but yeah let's get into agreement
we were drawn to christian healthcare
ministries because we both had young
families and we wanted to have more
children
and we had also just started a real
estate company and needed to find
healthcare coverage that would meet our
needs
chm is not health insurance but it is
christians helping other christians by
sharing each other's medical bills
the medical bill sharing from chm was
exactly the way the website described it
there were no surprises no bait and
switch no hidden agenda
chm did everything they said they would
by sharing all of our eligible needs
we like that it's a non-profit ministry
and that we were being better stewards
of our money
all while helping other families
established in 1981
and accredited by the better business
bureau chm
is here to meet the needs of your
growing family or small business
get started today and check us out at
chministries.org
backslash budget that's chministries.org
backslash budget we absolutely believe
in it
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is my
co-host today here on the air open
phones at triple eight eight
two five five two two five megan is with
us in tampa florida hi megan welcome to
the dave ramsey show i see on my screen
you're debt free
merry christmas yeah merry christmas
thank you
how much you pay off um
five 98 ninety three dollars that's a
lot of money megan
and how long did this take five years
wow and your range of income
um started off at forty eight thousand
two thirty and it's now fifty one
thousand
four one cool cool what do you do for a
living
i'm a speech and language pathologist at
elementary school
very good so what kind of debt was your
99
000 i had a visa
card through my bank i had a limited
card a macy's card
my car payment and student loans so
you're kind of normal
yeah deeply in debt and broke yes
how old are you i'm 39.
so what happened at 34 years old
i just lost track i was living on my own
just kept on spending my money what woke
you up
not being able to pay my bills really
and um overdraft from my
checking account from my savings account
and just
um god really i mean you know who woke
me up too
and did that yeah so just looking at the
overdrafts and the
no money scare you yes
so you're scared straight yes love it
me too yeah me too i don't ever want to
go back
note me either life is too freaking
short
i remember one night precisely i can i
could take you to the living room
and the desk i was sitting at i can see
it in my mind as
clear as anything i tried to balance the
checkbook back in the old days we used
to reconcile
a checkbook by hand it was not on the
computer and it was certainly not on the
internet there wasn't
one and um when i balanced the checkbook
i realized
comparing it with the checks that the
bank had sent me that i had forgot to
post
some of them and that i was 400
in overdraft and i remember sweat on my
upper lip
i remember my heart racing i remember
sweating the palms of my hands
and it was cold cold sweat
i was so out of control and terrified
and on i just said i never won't be
there again ever
right i remember sitting at work at the
end of the day with a
co-worker friend and he would help me
balance out my checkbook
because i was awful at it
and it didn't work nope overdraft
overdraft overdraft so what'd you do
you hit the bottom you got scared
straight tell me what you did what was
the first thing you did
while i was attending a local church and
i was talking to a friend at church one
day telling her about my finances
and she wanted to know if i heard about
dave ramsey financial peace and i said
no so she was telling me more about it
and then she introduced me to aaron
littles who also
him and his wife did their debt scream
through you
i met aaron littles he talked to me more
about it
wanted to hear my story and he
offered to sponsor me to take the
financial peace university at the church
wow it was a blessing wow
blessing i'll bet you'll do that for
somebody someday won't you
yes yeah wow it's very cool five years
is a long grind what kept you going for
five years
i didn't want to disappoint god i didn't
want to disappoint aaron and i didn't
want to disappoint myself and i did not
want to
live paying other people back
so you just cap at it that's 60 months
you just kept at it kept at it kept
at it yeah you really got disgusted
yeah you got so disgusted it lasted five
years
three extra jobs on top of being a
speech path that's already a job that
takes a lot of patience and time
what were your job what was your job i
did
my first side job was home health care
so after my full-time job
i went and saw clients in their home and
i did that for the five years
and then within the school district
were offered what's called t pay roll so
we're able to sit in on
staffing meetings and i would get paid
for that
and then another friend offered me a
side job to work under her for doing
brand
ambassador where i went into grocery
stores liquor stores and i
handed out samples of wine and liquor
for like 18 to possibly 25
an hour for three hours that's how you
made it five years
let's be honest it was the alcohol and
lots of alcohol
yeah so i did that off and on
um that was you know sporadic here and
there
and then aaron he offered me two years
ago he offered
me to work on the side doing his
recruiting company that he um
built up so i would do that after work
as well
recruiting nurses via the phone
this guy has made sure you won oh yeah
he is a great mentor
he's amazing what a great mentor really
very proud of him very proud of you well
done all right rockstar you did this
you're a hero
i mean you bust through you're by
yourself three jobs
you lean in you keep at it you keep
scratching you keep clawing you're
scrappy
for five freaking years and you pay off
99
000 you are an impressive young woman
what now you get to mentor somebody else
like you've been mentored
there's a few people listening to this
one of them is just like you were
tell her how to do it what's the key to
getting out of debt
getting mad sitting down getting an
accountability partner
putting all your debts and monthly
income on a budget and
just go at it if you can get a second
job go for it
sell stuff stop eating out
stop buying stuff that you really don't
need
that's how to do it you did a lot of
sacrifice for five years was it worth it
it was it was
what's your big goal when you get done
with this and you got a pile of money
and you're a millionaire
you're a chris hogan everyday
millionaire what's your big goal what do
you want to do with money
to invest save give
be healthy enjoy life there you go
retire without any financial problems
there you go well done i'm so so proud
of you
i know aaron is we are all we all of us
at ramsey are
we love people like you you're an
incredible hero you're out there doing
it you're scratching and clawing and
making it happen
nobody handed you nothing you went and
took it
legally and morally took it well done
hard work sacrifice discipline
dirty words in america for some people
today uh you didn't wait on washington
to fix your life
you just went and fixed it i'm so proud
of you
well done thank you we've got a copy of
chris hogan's book for you everyday
millionaires and that is the next
chapter in
your story megan without a doubt that is
your next chapter you keep going
you keep now it's time to be intentional
not intense
and uh dial this thing up and make it
happen so
very very very well done all right 99
000 counted off in five years making 48
to 51
plus three jobs count it down let's hear
a debt-free scream
three two one i'm debt-free
[Music]
yes
yeah baby yeah
hey i don't care this is how it's done i
don't care how tough you think you are
a five-year grind
that is a gangster dude that is that's a
that's calluses man
man that's calluses that's not this is
not for the faint of heart this is not
for the wuss
you gotta be willing to step it up that
girl's a warrior man
she looked in the mirror for five years
and said i'm worth it i'm worth it you
don't want it you don't want her to draw
down on you
she's a warrior man should get her done
wow
she's got a trunk full of alcohol
samples she'll find a way
megan will find a way good for her
what a stud this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
merry christmas it's the most wonderful
time of the year i love
christmas are you still looking for
great christmas deals well our famous 10
sale is not over that means you can shop
over 50 of our best-selling books and
envelopes
only 10 or less you can get the number
one best seller of the total money
makeover chris hogan's number one
bestseller every day millionaires for 10
bucks
you can get dr john dolone's redefining
anxiety for 10 bucks and we extended our
discount on the starter envelopes you
can still get yours for only five
dollars stock up on books that'll help
you
and more importantly help a bunch of
people in your life yeah so like a
hundred bucks
will get you ten bucks this is known as
a good
deal so stock up get ready for 2021 time
to reset time to get going again
visit the online store daveramsey.com
backslash store
and get these great deals open phones at
triple eight
eight two five five two two five tiffany
is in
washington dc hi tiffany how are you
hey dave hey dr d happy holidays to you
guys
merry christmas to you how can we help
yeah so i just want to say thank you as
of february this year me and my husband
we eliminated two hundred
thousand dollars of debt ding ding
number two
look at you wow i would i will say that
your name was a bad word
first initially because i found you um
but he's slowly coming around
to base um he has no choice now but um
so we finished uh baby step three four
and five
now um the question i have is we
currently own
our town home and this was a pre-baby
um and we're looking to buy a single
family home we shut down crunched the
numbers and said that it's going to take
us about two years
to save the 20 down right on a home
right now on our our town home we have
pmi
and the question is do we take a portion
of the 20
to pay down our current mortgage to get
to you know eliminate the pmi
and save the rest in cash or do we just
save all of the money
the 20 in cash or throw everything at
the current mortgage knowing that we're
going to sell the home
it doesn't matter either way you're
going to get your money back how what's
going to get
what's going to cause you to have the
most money the fastest probably paying
it down and getting rid of the pmi
depending on how long you're going to
stay there but you're going to buy an
appraisal to get rid of the pmi
right and i call the the appraisal is
just 380 right the pmi that we pay um
monthly is 300 so i'm thinking we're
staying here
yeah it makes sense to get rid of it if
you can pay it down you're exactly right
and then you're going to sell the town
home and make the move to the other
place with a
with money that you've saved up and the
equity from the town home
right right and the new mortgage is
going to be a 15-year fixed where the
payment's no more than a fourth year
take-home pay
exactly exactly i just didn't know if it
was better to have the cash on hand
doesn't matter um so it so we're not
dependent on selling the townhome
they're gonna give you they're gonna
give you the cash when you sell the town
home so it doesn't matter it's gonna
turn back into cash
okay okay so either way we we do it
it really doesn't matter i would throw
it at the town home as fast and as hard
as i can
if you want to leave maybe an extra 10
000 or something out to the side for
earnest money or something because
you're probably going to do a
contingency sale
but in this market unless you're in some
kind of weird niche market you
shouldn't have any trouble flipping the
town home and getting the other deal
closed right on time
you shouldn't have any trouble at all so
very well thought out
very well done 200 congrats what a
moment in history
to pay off 200 000 february of 2020
yeah and then it happened and then i
could see your husband saying i don't
like i don't like it all right i'm in
i'm in tiffany we are geniuses yes we
are
tiffany you're lucky you've married me
[Laughter]
denver colorado linda's on the line hi
linda how are you
hi dave i'm doing great well i'm not
doing great but i have a couple of
questions for you
okay um um i
my mom is we just moved her closer to me
and she's in a memory care center
and my brother and i were um
designated as her powers of attorney and
um my brother passed away on december 6.
i'm so sorry linda and
um he left his 403b
to my mom and i was just wondering i
don't know what to do with it
and my son he he's one of your
financial stars and he suggested i call
you
oh my gosh i'm so sad what happened to
your brother honey
um he had sclerosis of the liver
okay and how old is your mom
my mom is 84. and how old are you
i am 59. okay all right well his 403 b
will go to her what i would tell you to
do is just go to
you're in control of it because you're
her power of attorney so you can move it
and do proper things with it um she is
the beneficiary
on the 403b so it pays out
and uh be in touch with that company and
let them know that you're going to roll
it
to an inherited ira
and you're going to and you're going to
and that will there will be no taxes on
it now but there
is a required withdrawal uh 1 10
per year for 10 years
of the balance what's the balance on it
i think it's around 250 000 okay
so go to daveramsey.com and click on
smart
investor and it'll drop down a list of
the people we recommend in your area
we're not
in the investment business but we have a
network of people that
have the heart of a teacher and they're
going to gently and carefully walk you
through this they're not sales people
they're teachers
okay and they're going to show you
exactly what to do and how to do it and
they'll help you pick out some mutual
funds for your mom
to roll this this ira into
and um and then it will have to begin to
draw down one tenth and they can teach
you all the details about that
it's it's a fairly simple transaction
but it has a lot of pieces of paper to
it
okay and they can walk you through it
and where it's not overwhelming
while you're dealing with all this stuff
that you're dealing with i mean you got
mom in the
memory center and and you've lost your
brother you don't need a bunch of stuff
stacked on you but you also need to pay
attention enough so you know what
happened
okay even in the midst of your even in
the midst of your stress and your grief
so click smart vester at daveramsey.com
it'll drop down a list of the smart
vester pros
in your area you can contact one that
you choose talk to them
and here's the thing i want you when you
sit with them on behalf of your mom to
have a good
listen to this word a good feeling
okay that will give you peace
that you're dealing with someone that
you feel good about
okay because you don't need to feel
jerked around right now
okay if you don't have a good feeling
get up and walk out
okay but you should because you should
be dealing with someone who's
understands empathizes with what you're
going through and
wants to teach you so that later when
you wake up
six months from now you're like what did
i do again i forget
you need to know what you did okay okay
and they can help you walk through that
and linda
was life with your brother pretty tough
was what say that again how was life
with your brother were y'all close
yes you were so this christmas before
christmas maybe christmas eve
i want you to spend some time by
yourself
and i want you to put the money stuff
aside and i want you to write your
brother
a long letter and let him know how much
you love him
and you may read that letter to your mom
on christmas eve or christmas morning
but don't don't make yourself too busy
this holiday
to not experience the loss of missing
your brother okay
okay you have a lot of duty and a lot of
responsibility and it would be easy to
walk past the emotion
yeah yeah i'm sorry that you lost him
and it was kind
of okay yeah i hate that for you
yeah i'm so sorry yeah but that's the
technical tactical thing
you're going to roll it to an inherited
ira with a smartvestor pro
and you're going to understand what
you're doing and you're going to have
peace about it
dave taking this exact same situation
let's
let's get another scenario where mom is
on medicaid
does this mess up her medicaid now with
an inherited ira yeah
okay okay medicaid is welfare when you
have 250 000
you don't need your office that's right
okay yeah
different it's a different scenario but
i mean welfare you don't need welfare
when you've got a quarterback
that's right yeah and there's nothing
wrong with that by the way that's a good
thing
that's a good thing that puts this hour
the dave ramsey show in the books
[Music]
[Music]
welcome to the dave ramsey show you can
be intentional about your character
you can have money and a career you
are the hero in your story
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions
broadcasting from the dollar car rental
studios it's the dave ramsey show
where that is dumb cash is king and the
paid off home mortgage has taken the
place of the bmw
as the status symbol of choice i'm dave
ramsey your host thank you for joining
us america we're so glad you're here dr
john deloney ramsey personality
best-selling author of the book
redefining anxiety what it is
what it's not and how to get your life
back
is my co-host today here on the air
we're taking your calls at triple eight
eight two five
five two two five that's triple eight
eight two five
five two two five peter starts off this
hour in phoenix arizona hi peter how are
you
hello dave thanks for taking my call
sure man what's up
well um i'm 64 my wife and i have been
married for 33 years
and uh we have four children and our old
our youngest child has autism he was
adopted
late in our marriage and uh so
uh we're trying to provide for him after
we retire
uh we know he's gonna lose he's gonna
lose my company's insurance as soon as
we retire
if we when we go on uh on our social
security so
we're trying to you know provide for him
and make sure that he's taken care of
okay and now the specific question is
how do we do that you know and i we've
got a lot of people that uh you know
aren't experts giving us advice
and uh you know one one person said you
know uh you need to get a physician's
letter of capacity
so that he can get us a social security
uh you know uh so that he's so that he's
taken care of
now we don't we don't anticipate him
leaving our house
uh because of his because of his
capabilities uh
he's he's higher on the spectrum but
still he
uh we don't he's vulnerable you know out
there and we don't think that uh
you know he's ready to make the movie
he's 26 years old i'm sorry
23 years old and uh
so we're we're kind of at a crux right
now as to what we should do
okay um
the truthful answer is i'm not positive
what you should do
so what do i do when i'm in a situation
like that
uh i would um do what you did i would
call somebody i thought was an expert
and apparently i'm not but
but uh anyway yeah i would call xander
insurance
uh or someone like them that is a an
insurance
broker that brokers health insurance for
several different companies
in multiple states now obviously you're
going to want someone that
brokers insurance in arizona in the
insurance world
where we have an unusual case and you're
trying to get a
an unusual type of insurance or an
unusual situation insured
we call it their make they make a market
meaning they find an insurance company
that'll cover it
and so like you hear bizarre stuff like
a pianist
insuring their hands or something with
lloyds of london that's called making a
market
they found an insurer that would do
something unusual this is not that
unusual but it is
it is a nuanced situation that i don't
know the answer to so i would talk to
some people in the insurance world and
say okay what are my options what can we
buy
can a 23 year old the high functioning
autism
living with their parents buy their own
insurance
uh yeah i suppose they could i think
that's very possible they could just
simply
under obamacare pre-existing condition
doesn't count against you
i suppose that he could just buy
insurance of course that's going to mean
you're buying it you're paying for it
but it would be as if he's doing the
transaction
with something like a blue cross blue
shield or something uh
i think that's possible but i can't slam
my fist down and say
i know the answer to your question
because i don't so
what i would do in your situation as i
would talk to insurance
brokers and the reason for that is that
means they represent a whole bunch of
different companies
and their real person they represent is
you and they're just trying to find a
place to slot you
and give you the best deal that's the
best deal on health insurance it's the
best deal on car
insurance and homeowners insurance it's
the best deal on life insurance
is is to not go with a captive company
that only sells
their products but instead a company a
broker that sells products of
many different companies and that's an
example of that is xander insurance so i
just call those guys
and see if they have you know if they do
repping
for health insurance in phoenix if not
they can give you a recommendation to
someone that does
and i think they do and then they can
they can help you figure out
how to insure this under the affordable
care act
also known as obamacare and um there's a
lot of
things that you can uh force in those
situations now the fact that he's not a
miner
may play into it but he's under 26 so
that and he's in your household so that
should play into it
so it should be able to treat it just
like he was a kid living at home with
you
and it's under your insurance but um but
it's not your insurance now so i don't
know
i don't know how it's going to play out
uh but i think it can be done
i think you've just got to scratch
around and solve the issue
and then the second part of the equation
is you've got to solve the issue for
how much of your wealth is allocated to
a trust
upon your death for his care and who's
going to be in charge of his care
and managing the wealth that you leave
to create an income for him to eat with
upon your death and that's the second
part of the equation is the long-term
planning for him
and that's a special needs trust in most
cases in your will is what you do with
that that part i do know a little bit
about
so i wish i could just give you the
answer i just don't know the nuances of
that stuff it's not my world
and i i i love that you're that you're
there for him
that's a pretty cool situation
tough world john yeah and one note to
folks with
kids 23 year olds 22 year olds 16 year
olds 15 year olds of
with medium to high functioning autism
dad mentioned he's doing well but he's
still vulnerable so we want to keep him
here
i always want folks to lean up against
that efficacy the skill sets that those
young people have give them the
opportunity to get a part-time job
a close a job where they will be
successful
they they earn dignity there they earn
their own money there
and they begin to develop social skills
especially if they got a coach with them
that can really move beyond this initial
diagnosis
with especially with high functioning
autistic kids
they are just extraordinary human beings
and can find places where they can be
really successful
and so good for you yeah very important
dakari is in
washington d.c hi dakari how are you
hey john how are you today sorry i
apologize hey dave how are you today
we're both here it's all good
what's up man how can we help um so
i am 26 right now and i live at home
with my parents
and um it sounds like you're whispering
are you like in an apartment
okay you don't want to find out i'm at
work
all right all right i thought you were
hiding at your parents house all right
no no no i'm busy during the day at the
very least
okay um so i'm i'm 26
i live at home and basically i'm trying
to figure out right now
if it's best to buy um
and or to rent now just some context i
would be buying a
four unit owner-occupied multi-family no
um no can you pay cash for it
can i pay cash how about this let's do
this
asia fha i'm going to hold you over the
break
because um we'll talk to you i want to
be able to flush this out fully here
after this break so stay with us and
we'll be right back
[Music]
folks it's an honor to tell you about
the army national guard
not only are they big supporters of our
high school curriculum
but they also give you the opportunity
to impact your local communities
whether your goals are to get an
education serve your country
or have a better life the army national
guard can help get you there
plus they offer unbelievable financial
benefits
secure your future today visit
nationalguard.com
to find out more
[Music]
so
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today we are talking with dakari
in
washington dc 26 years old thinking
about moving out
thought about buying a four-plex and
live in one of the four plexes
and that's about how far we got in the
discussion is that a fair summary of
what you told us so far sir
exactly exactly dave cool all right john
so dakari
um i was trying to cram it in there
before the break and then i thought i
would breathe a little bit and i try to
force this on you
here's the deal do you have 20 down on
this four plex
um so my understanding is with owner
occupancy i could do
under fha so 3.5 and no i don't have 20
down yeah so what you don't want to do
as a 26 year old
is put 3 percent down scratch and claw
and borrow that 3 percent
and slide right in and then have
something come up
and you've got to feel the rent on those
other three places
and so you are way way over your head
and i know you want to get out
and you're trying to figure out a quick
way to build wealth you feel like you're
behind because you're 26. how much money
do you have saved sir
um 26 000. and what are you making
so just so 45k um
and i do work for a property management
company so i'm kind of
uh uh i'm already in the game a little
bit
yeah that's what gave you the bug yeah
that's what that i was the same way man
i got my real estate license when i
turned 18 and i couldn't wait to start
buying real estate it was my favorite
thing in the world
and i want you to get some real estate i
just don't i'm with john i don't want
the real estate to get
you okay step one move out and rent for
six months
okay during that time you learn to pay
your own bills
you emotionally separate from mom and
dad that last degree
and you're standing on your own two feet
and there's some stuff happen
spiritually relationally all that you
get all that out of the way you buy your
own freaking couch and that kind of
stuff
and um then kind of from that solid
platform we start talking about whether
you buy something or not
and um you know i i don't ever tell
somebody to buy something with three
percent down three percent down means
you can't afford it
okay okay for me because i want you to
have more margin than that i don't want
this thing to sneak up on you
because here's the deal if you have
three tenants
and you're one of the and you're the
fourth and uh there's something like
let's just say something like a pandemic
hit
who would have ever thought right and
the tenants the tenants were all servers
at local restaurants
and they all lost their jobs and they
can't pay
and you've got to pay the attorney to
evict them and you have to pay the
payment
and you have absolutely no cash because
you put what little cash you had into
this deal
you're what's known as screwed
i see see and i've been there and i love
real estate and i really want you to buy
some real estate
but i by the time i was 26 i had four
million dollars worth
and i had too much borrowed on it and
the bank got sold to another bank
flipped me on my head and i spent two
and a half years going bankrupt losing
everything i owned
i don't want you to have that experience
okay let's see go slower with more cash
and more margin so that after you put
the payment down
the down payment down there's a lot of
wiggle room in your life and there's a
big old pile of cash
laying there in case stuffed bad stuff
goes out like the heating and air system
not in case it will it will go out right
yes not not so
not not so if but when right when crap
happens and you've been managing
property so look at it from the owner's
perspective they get the repair bills
the expenses they get the vacancies
they get the non-paying tenants who go
into chapter 13
or worse chapter 11 and you don't get
paid for nine months and you can't evict
them because you cannot
file on them while they're in there um
you know we had a moratorium in my
county on evictions
uh during the pandemic we had this in
our state
the state uh supreme court came down and
said no evictions for two months
during the pandemic and we had a guy who
had nothing to do with the pandemic
he was just a twerp and he wasn't paying
his bill and we needed to get him out we
couldn't get him out
we're stuck we're sitting there of
course we didn't have any payments so it
was no big deal we worked it through but
you know if you had a bunch of that kind
of stuff pile up on you man
real estate gets less than fun it is not
a broke people's game
but here's what i've got really high
hopes for dakari he's 26 years old
he's already thinking he's got thousands
of dollars in savings
yep right against us not a huge salary
so he's a saver he's a planner he's got
the wheels cranking yep
he just needs the right the right plan
and he's going to make it happen yeah
just
be the tortoise not the hair yeah move
out
rent something cheap get you a used
couch buy your own groceries
pile up some more cash work an extra job
pile up some more cash then do your
first deal
12 months after you move out at the
earliest
dan is in denver hi dan welcome to the
dave ramsey show
hello hi dave and john and uh thanks for
all that you do
i would call myself a financial piece
zealot
and that's kind of a strange car
question for you all right
so i have uh i guess we have the need to
buy a new car in the next
year or so and the cars that we're
looking at the two models
and quite frankly they didn't exist a
couple years ago so i was wondering is
it better to buy
a 2019 used model or a 2020
uh model that's 25k so used ones 30k
and the new ones 25k but they would both
meet our needs
what's your household income uh about
200k
that's nice very well good okay you
talking about a tesla
oh no not a tesla there are hybrids dude
oh hybrids okay
all right you said it didn't exist a few
years ago so i couldn't figure out what
you're talking about but the uh
all right so uh and what's your net
worth sir
uh sure it's uh probably about 700k
okay all right uh our recommendation has
always been not to buy a brand new
vehicle
until your net worth is over a million
you're going to be there very shortly
with your income and with i assume that
700 is invested and it's growing
as well so you're going to be there
before you know it i
personally did not buy any new cars
after going broke and starting over and
adopting these rules i personally did
not buy new cars until i had a 10
million
net worth but uh but the point being
that a new car goes down in value so
fast that you want the discipline of not
having
invested in something that's losing
ground that fast you're kind of on the
bubble
you make a lot of money and you got a
lot of money
you're almost there so i mean you could
cheat
and pull it off it's not going to
destroy you uh what i'm trying to do is
keep somebody from making 50 000
a year uh with a 20 000 net worth
from buying a brand new car and then
they lose eight thousand dollars the
first 10 seconds they own the stupid
thing you know when you drive it off the
curve
curb when it's brown and it goes blunt
that was a 10 grand sound
you know and so that's that's what you
don't want to have a ten thousand dollar
thing happen to you when you don't have
any money
right but in your case with the money
with the numbers you're giving me dan if
they're all accurate
i mean you're almost there and so you
you're more than capable of making this
decision on your own
i personally would probably go and buy
the used one
just as an act of discipline a financial
discipline
just to say i'm not going to start
acting like i'm
high on the hawk because you're not that
high on the hall get you're doing
really well though you're doing really
well
obviously you're you got a huge income
and that's
piling up for you fast so you know
it's not going to cause you to not make
millionaire status
regardless of which way you make this
decision but i like
the discipline of sticking with the
guideline of until i have at least a
million dollar net worth i'm not going
to buy a brand new car
because they go down in value so quickly
that first year
and dave one of my favorite things to do
is to look at successful people look at
wise people
and listen to their little t truths the
the sayings they give
but watch their big t truths how they
live and for everybody listening to this
who doesn't have
hundred thousand dollars network and a
two hundred thousand dollar income
i want them to hear what it sounds like
with somebody with that sort of
resources that sort of income earning
power
still trying to make a wise decision
still thinking about the purchase
that's how you get seven hundred
thousand dollars when you ask questions
about twenty five thousand dollar
purchases yeah
that's how you accumulate that money ten
bucks at a time ten bucks at a time
exactly good for you dan exactly he has
the he's got the right stuff that's how
he's that's how he got there that's a
good point john
very good this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
one of the things that makes the dave
ramsey show unique from other shows
is that we genuinely care about our
listeners
that's why we are very intentional about
choosing
our advertisers blinds.com
offers high quality window treatments at
unbelievable prices
and then their customer service is truly
unbeatable
they make it simple to shop for blinds
shades and interior shutters from home
with easy online ordering and
free shipping right to your door and
blinds.com
will help you every step of the way just
like they've helped
thousands of my listeners with free
design help
by phone and online plus they guarantee
the perfect fit
go today and take advantage of this
week's
special offer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today this is the dave ramsey
show on the debt-free stage
right here in ramsey solutions lobby
raphael and jessica are with us hey guys
how are you how you doing dave
welcome how are you doing john what's up
brother where do you all live so we live
in san antonio texas
awesome how much debt have you paid off
76 thousand dollars
how long did this take 17 months wow you
kicked it
and your range of income during that
time from 60 000 to 104.
now there's a bump we went to school she
got a job
and uh look at you throwing her under
the bus
you got a job because i'm a disabled
veteran so uh she was usually just
at home taking care of me and then i was
like hey you got to get out there start
making some money for us so we can
pursue pursue what we what we really
want to do in life i love it thank you
for your service yeah
so what kind of debt was the 76 000. it
was a lot man
i bought a car well i had i originally
bought a truck without telling her
um yeah i didn't listen yeah
i bought a truck without telling her
yeah how do you live through that
i don't know
i'm still here so yeah i did that and
then um we
thought we needed a family car because
we had our second child at the moment
um so we bought a new 2018 dodge journey
sure um traded in the truck for that so
it was like negative equity into the new
one we paid forty thousand dollars for a
twenty seven
thousand dollar car um that went we were
on
we um what do i say underwater yeah we
were underwater we went upside down in
net within like six months
wow um so yeah um in the last five years
i got scammed
um we blew 27 000 in a
furniture store in like two minutes that
was awesome
it's like you're on a game show it was
awesome dave
uh we did that and then like we just got
sick and tired we had our second child
and then like we
we was making all this money it was like
60 grand at the time we had nothing to
show for it
um so i got mad it's like um i started
calling like some of our
our companies and say hey can we like
postpone these bills
can we do it like three months out
because we just bought a house at that
moment too
um so it just felt like every time the
money came in
it went out um on the second day of the
month so like we were just
eating ramen noodles at the time just
yeah just to make it by trying to make
ends meet
yeah yeah it sucked i hated it i didn't
like it you're eating ramen noodles at a
really fancy kitchen table
it was nice it was a really nice table
it was glass
all that you pull it out it rotated in
the middle and everything it was
nice and those ramen noodles tasted just
the same
it was it was really good we had the
shrimp flavor the chicken
man all the different powder peppers all
of them like it was nice
so nice what did you do when you got
disgusted
uh we had a talk um we originally uh
went to financial peace
in california that's where i was
stationed camp middleton so um
we originally had it there but we were
still doing dave ish we didn't have an
accountability partner
so you flunked we flunked the class yeah
we never even got the certificate so it
was okay
it was sad we left we moved to san
antonio and then we met these great we
met this great church called cbc
uh we met friends there started a small
group and then
they they seen a book in our house like
hey what are you doing with the dave
ramsey book man can i borrow it
and then they got serious about it that
that became our financial
um accountability partner um and then we
just started in january of last year and
we just went booking it
okay so you knew what to do you just had
to go back to yeah yeah we knew what to
do and we needed an accountability
partner otherwise we would just
still spend whatever you want to keep
you out of the furniture store
[Laughter]
stay away from the furniture yeah that's
nice furniture dave
[Laughter]
all right so yes ago we haven't heard
from you tell us about your your
experience in this journey
it was really rough um for a good while
i
just kind of had to sit him down and
talk to him and tell him that i felt
like he was dragging me
but we we came together and like he said
our accountability group
just kind of helped us through the the
whole process and
now we're here so you you didn't mind
the your financial
situation you liked that furniture i did
you liked that
i did at the time okay but it was like
you said
it was just ramen noodles so
oh money yeah well way to go
now that you did it you're the other
side of it talk to somebody who has
taken the class
years ago and fallen off the wagon so to
speak
and um what does it feel like to get
back on it and go okay now game on
well it's excited um after seeing the
first debt
go away doing the steps uh do the
smallest first and then do the largest
um it was just motivating just checking
it off the list on the on the
refrigerator
um i would say to them just just don't
give up
um stop eating out because
you might eat out small but like those
little purchases add up throughout the
mountain we we noticed that we were
spending like
nearly eight hundred dollars on like
food just eating out and stuff like that
yeah
so we stopped eating out um had the
accountability partner
and we just we just stayed focused like
we knew what we wanted for our kids
um that was our why yeah we didn't want
them to uh
relive
we live
a family curse of just being broke all
the time
i didn't like it so i want to set them
up for
financial financial peace that's why we
did it we had a really strong why
and you did you did you you broke the
chain didn't you
you are you literally changed your
family tree
that's pretty cool man i'm so proud of
you and bigger than the money
very well done you taught those two kids
what a married couple can accomplish
when they come together
you taught uh you taught your kids what
it looks like to submit to
accountability partners
you changed everything about their
future brother
yeah because they were watching you the
whole time the whole time
they absorbed all of mama's temper
tantrums
it was a lot all of it yeah she was
upset with me we had to um
we had a lot of fights along the way but
it was worth it she was like you're all
about the money i'm like no no
because every time we got paid it was
like hey let's throw it here let's throw
it there let's get rid of this one let's
get rid of that one because i was just i
was just motivated by just seeing
that big pile of debt just disappear
every month
man i'm so proud of you guys well done
very very well done so what are the
secrets
to getting out of debt you got a big why
now and that's that's obvious
what are the secrets sell sell a bunch
of stuff
sell everything a shot sell everything
we sold the entertainment system
we sold the car we sold the couch we
don't even have a couch anymore that's
crazy
we sold uh that dining room table
everything we bought with the glass
dining room
you know when there's something that
from switch that flips and you go it's
just
stuff is this stuff like dave we were
selling plastic i wanted it was crazy
i won i wanted my family
tree changed more than i want a glass
table with a spinny thing in the middle
yeah it was worth it i mean that's like
the opposite of shallow right it is
well done i don't want to live inside of
one of the greatest culinary cities on
earth
eating ramen noodles right oh man no you
don't
want to get some good food in san
antonio hey man your mouth is watering
mine
all right we got a copy of chris hogan's
book for you everyday millionaires
that's definitely the next chapter in
your story
we gonna get the kiddos into the
debt-free scream let's do it all right
what are their names and ages
this is rafael junior and leonardo i'm
trying to ride a ninja turtle there you
go
two more two more all right lots of
ninja turtle action here
all right seventy six thousand dollars
paid off in 17 months
making 60 to 104. but the most important
thing was
the family curse has changed the family
tree has changed and you're
looking in the guy's face the gal's face
who changed it right here
they did it count it down let's hear a
debt free scream
three two one we're dead free
[Applause]
oh man
you have honor to where you came from
but you don't have to repeat
where you came from that's the magic
right you don't have to repeat the
things that they did that were wrong you
can change
your family tree you can honor people
and recognize that there's not a curse
that can't be broken they didn't have
the tools i've got them
the curse can be broken with the truth
yes and the action
when you put the truth and the action in
place you can change it
this is the dave ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day second
corinthians 9 7 each one must give as he
is decided in his heart not reluctantly
or under compulsion for god loves
a cheerful giver winston churchill said
we make a living by what we get
we make a life by what we give
2020 probably wasn't the year you hoped
for well no duh
you might have to pause some of your
money goals like paying off debt just to
keep your house running
but a new year is here and you can clean
up the debt
and you can get control of your money
and you can get back on track
if you got off track faster than you
think
and that's exactly what happens when you
get ramsey plus
it's our step-by-step money plan that
will help you pay off your debt as fast
as
possible so you can start spending and
saving how you want
and here's how you learn the practical
ways to pay off more debt and save for
emergencies
you'll plan your spending in a budget so
you can even find more money to throw at
the debt
and you'll track your progress we're
going to show you everything it's
financial peace university wrapped into
their ramsey plus
no matter how this year is gone you can
make 2021 the year you get rid of your
debt for good
so try ramsey plus for free if you want
to try it
text the word trial two thirty three
seven eight nine that's trial two three
three seven eight nine dr john deloney
ramsey personality is my co-host today
here on the air
rodrico is in san francisco hey rodriko
how are you
hi dave how are you better than i
deserve what's up
i need help or some guidance of how to
tackle seventy one thousand two hundred
and seventy eight dollars of debt
um it's seven credit cards total length
35
875. one person alone
total lean 11 611
one car loan totaling 11 626
a student loan of uh six thousand eight
hundred and eight dollars
and a tax bill of five thousand three
hundred and fifty seven
dollars and uh what's overwhelming for
me
is that the minimum payments on all this
stuff totals to uh
1846. and i'm just not sure
the best way to tackle this whole debt
and what's your income
um income is uh 39 000. how much is your
rent
um rent i'm fortunate right now to be
staying at a place where it's 500 bucks
at the moment which is amazing
what's at the moment mean you're not
going to be there long
or i'm going to be here for at least
a year and a half okay because that's
unheard of in san francisco
you said very fortunate it's more like a
miracle
yeah okay good that's wonderful i'm
happy for you
okay so you live in one of the more
expensive cities in the world you know
that
yeah making thirty nine thousand dollars
how old are you
uh 31 single okay and so for
approximately eight to ten years you've
been spending more than you make pretty
steadily
yes thus the personal loan thus the
credit card debt
the car purchased when you didn't have
any money so it's debt
and the student loan lingers from the
days back in college
yeah is this a summary of how we got
here or did i read something wrong
nope summary perfectly okay
and so
i think there's two things that have to
happen
and they both have to happen in order
for you to turn this math around because
the math is kicking your butt
and you got no wiggle room there's no
margin in the numbers you're giving me
and uh you've kind of come to that had
that come to jesus moment with the
arithmetic right
and so um uh uh
ones there's two sides there's income
and out go and we call it shovel to
whole ratio
your shovel is your income the whole is
your is your 71 thousand dollars in debt
1800 bucks a month
that's the whole and so you have a a
medium to small
shovel especially given the city that
you live in
and if you were in abilene texas it'd be
different
okay but uh in the city that you're in
that's tough and 39 000 is tough
and uh then the hole you're in is
substantial so you have a medium to
small shovel and a large hole
so we need to change that ratio we got
to do something with your income
what do you do for a living man right
now i'm
working at a housekeeper in a hospital
okay
all right so you need a side gig that
pays
and it can be something as simple as
delivering pizza and you can make an
extra 1500 a month doing that that's 18
000 a year
we just added 50 to your income and
you're working four or five nights a
week your party days are over
you got to get an extra job or three and
because 1500 bucks a month
right now changes your whole life
because you can begin to clean this mess
up
call the student loan people put it on a
hardship deferral don't pay them a dime
right now
cut up your credit cards and then the
last step in addition to adding extra
income is you have got to get on a
detailed budget now the good news is you
really know exactly where you are you
are a detailed person
you did not give me vague innuendo about
your debt you gave me exactly what it
was
which tells me positive things about you
so use that exacting part of your
personality
jump on i'm gonna put you i'm gonna pay
for it i'm gonna put you in ramsey plus
for a year and i want you to go to the
financial peace university class i want
you to get on every dollar
this syncs up with your bank it's the
best budgeting app in the world
and i'm going to give it to you all free
because i've been right where you are
and scared and you're scared
yeah thanks and rodrigo i want to toss
one more thing into the mix
do you have somebody there in town that
you trust that you can be open with
yeah i do okay you need to have a hard
hard conversation about living
in one of the most expensive places on
earth being 31
and broke broke you may have to make
some new geographic decisions
some change of profession decisions
and this is one of those moments that
out of the ash of this fire you're going
to make some meaning and you're going to
you're going to launch out and be a
totally new rodrigo in 2021
but somebody you have to sit down and
have a hard conversation about
why am i living here why am i
committed to doing this work at 31
is this what i'm going to be doing at 41
am i going to be doing this at 51
or am i going to really bite the bullet
for 18 months 24 months and change the
entire
trajectory of my life yeah
so i you hold on the line kelly will
pick up and we'll get you signed up for
ramsey plus
i'm not sure this is right but i'll tell
you what i think i'm hearing
no one wins the super bowl by accident
it is a series of intentional acts
and so far the first decade of your
adulthood
everything has happened to you you have
not happened to it
you've kind of gone ah i'll take this
job yeah
i'll live there i'm gonna buy that car
let's go out tonight
and all those all added up to a pile of
crap
and so you now you're ready because you
called us and you knew what you were
walking into
you're ready to turn the corner and
start going
uh this is not happening to me anymore
i'm gonna make decisions now
intentional be intentional about my
career yes i'm gonna be intentional and
disciplined about this
and the good news is you're a very
detailed person and you will lay out a
and map out a detailed strategy and then
you can execute it but you don't
accidentally end up
in you know if you leave home and you
want to
leave san francisco and you want to go
to seattle you don't accidentally end up
there
nope on a sunday afternoon drive you
have a freaking map and you go
turn here turn here fill up with gas
stop and go the bathroom turn here
drive here and the gps will yell at you
turn around if you're going the wrong
way
and you've got to get on a gps for your
life and
start being very intentional about every
step because i
kind of think i might be wrong but i'm
kind of reading between the lines
that this has all just been path of
least resistance
ah that job's there earl nightingale
used to say
one of the fathers of motivational
speaking that
in every decade there's a group of
people who spend more time picking out a
suit of clothes than their career
[Music]
and that's just normal we get
sidetracked and we put our attention to
the wrong
things so that puts us our the dave
ramsey show in the books thanks john
good work
thank you so much dr john deloney james
childs in the booth
is our producer kelly daniel is our
associate producer and phone screener
i am dave ramsey your host will be back
with you before you know it
in the meantime remember there's
ultimately only one way to financial
peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace christ
jesus
[Music]
[Music]
you